let's just come back to this guy it is
deceptively simple said what is the
problem that you encounter when you try
and differentiate whence this log
function what's what's different about
it it's a different base right so if the
base is not what you want just change
the base to be what you want so
surprisingly you use the change of base
law right so you might recall right now
if you have something like this you can
rephrase this as two logs right log of
this divided by look at that and you can
choose any base you like right now I
think I'm probably gonna choose the base
that I know something about right so
really this guy here this function I'm
going to rewrite as log x over log and
can I be to prove change of base rule
for you again happy to do that
but there's the result like I could have
chosen any base I wanted to 300 minus 1
but I'll choose equals I know something
about what's your done back it becomes
quite simple right 1 over log a this
part here is just a number it's just a
constant right so therefore I can bring
it out the front and then I'm just
appreciating this again right so in fact
it's 1 over X from here and a 1 over log
n which just comes out that's just a
constant coefficient so there you go it
has a kind of nice symmetry when you say
here the log a term appears again right
now let's have a go at this is nobody I
heard that I prepared you sufficiently
to see something like this because we
had to do so what kind of treats here in
order to like the problem here is that
it's not in the edge of the power
something right that's the issue that
you do
this is more in common I suppose with an
exponential function than it does with a
polynomial function okay
you pretty much cannot twist this into
any shape to get to this but you can
twist this to get this I will show you
okay space X I can rephrase that so it's
in place even right because I can say
that X Y or call this X is equal to e to
the power log X do you remember that I
knew I took advantage of that identity
yesterday when I was proving some of
these results is right so I'm just going
to substitute this single X here for
this so it's going to be e to the power
log X and that's raised to the power X
that's not too groundbreaking right I'm
just using the center because of what
powers a kid they should multiply
together this is e to the power X X and
now lo and behold all I have is chain
rule for an exponential function right
this is nice and neat and tidy right all
I have to do is differentiate the inside
and then differentiate the outside right
okay so that's part over there isn't it
like that inside function and see if you
call that you you call that B I'm just
gonna go V u - plus pop me up that's it
and it's going to be you me gosh do you
agree with this that is the visa tis the
B - right so at AA I've differentiated
in the inside function up in the power
right and now to differentiate the
outside well it's even the power of blah
blah blah blah just led you back where
you started right so I'm just gonna
write that as X that's all the Lakewood
really that was the Han time now I've
seen the tidied up a little bit
I've got log and +1 that and then on the
MTA I got what they do this either book
X log X time I think that I introduced
that to make it easier to differentiate
I don't need to this is actually once
the one assignment X to the X is clearly
a simpler way to phrase it so I'm just
gonna go back to see and I'm done I have
to
okay now um done hi this is exactly the
way I would do it by the way I present
you need to try to approach it in
another venture this mode is there
quicker or more efficient or less
error-prone way to solve this question
but the textbook does mention in
question 17 if you've had a look at it
and I get going in this other way right
there's another method to doing it so on
these methods both had names and so the
method they were just used really was
about expressing everything we basically
okay so I'm gonna call this expressing
with